[Fabien] Salut à vous, peuple des internets.
Aujourd’hui, une vidéo avec 2 personnes
A savoir Monsieur Vérino de la chaîne Vérino
et Mademoiselle Céline H de la chaîne Céline H.
Nous allons jouer avec les prédictions les plus ratées de l'histoire.
Tu sais en mentalisme, on aime bien faire des prédictions, dire il va se passer ça,
et après il se passe ça...
Il y a eu des gens,
très connus,
qui ont prédit des choses de ouf
Du style internet, ça ne marchera jamais!
le but du jeu pour eux c'est de trouver qui a dit ça
ou qu'est ce qu'a dit untel
Et celui des 2 qui va marquer le plus de points,
aura le droit de prendre le réseau social de son choix chez son adversaire
et d'y poster ce qu'il veut.
Tu sais pourquoi c'est pas mal ? Parce que moi je ne peux pas perdre
Alors on pourrait se dire que j'ai fait des grandes recherches partout sur internet
c'est vrai ! J'ai commencé par faire des grandes recherches jusqu'à temps que je trouve ce livre
par contre, j'ai été honnête.
C'est à dire que j'ai contacté l'éditeur pour savoir si j'avais le droit de parler de ce livre
[Vérino] Ce n'est pas un placement de produit ?
[F] Ce n'est pas un placement de produit
[V] Ecoutez bonjour, si vous ne me connaissez pas, c'est pas grave...
vous pouvez me connaitre du coup, bien joué *rire*
c'est la présentation la plus nulle de l'histoire des présentations
[F] Ouais
[Céline] Tu as convaincu personne
[V] Je suis absolument nul en présentation
ne venez pas me découvrir je m'appelle....
comment... qu'est ce que je pourrais dire?
[F] Tania Dutel
[V] Tania Dutel, allez découvrir Tania Dutel
[C] Et bien oui, et bien voilà Céline, Céline H voilà
donc euh... hein et voilà *rire*
Pire que lui donc...
[V] donc... on est bien content de se retrouver ici le matin
[C] Ah oui
[V] Je tiens à dire qu'on tourne le matin
[F] Oui c'est vrai
Je sais pas si je garderai cette séquence
les gens vont se désabonner de vos chaînes,
ils vont y aller, ils vont trouver des gens abonnés et ils vont leur dire "désabonne toi"
Bon je tiens les scores les amis
A qui parlait Dick Rowe, c'est le mec qui a dit la citation que je vais dire quand il a dit :
"Les groupes à guitare vont disparaître"
[C] Beatles
[F] Bravo !
[C] C'est vrai?
[F] Oui tout à fait
[C] Allez... *joie*
[V] Je ne connais même pas ce groupe, jamais entendu parler des Beatles
*rire de Céline*
[F] La phrase complète était :
"Retournez à Liverpool, M. Epstein, les groupes à guitares vont bientôt disparaître"
il s'adressait aux Beatles en refusant de signer leur premier contrat
[V] Oh la vache c'est tellement génial
[F] Et il s'est mangé 3 cou*lles
c'est à dire qu'il en a mangé 2 il en a une qui a repoussé et il l'a bouffé aussi
[C] Ah je commence à me... à prendre confiance
[V] Ah ouais *rire*
[C] Excuse moi je prends de la place. Pardon
[F] Qui a dit en parlant des ordinateurs, des capacités de stockage
"640 kilo-octet ça devrait être assez pour tout le monde"
*Rire de Vérino*
[V] ...
[F] "640 kilo-octet ça devrait être assez pour tout le monde"
Tu as à peu près la valeur de ce que fait 640 Kilo-octet?
[C] Absolument pas
Alors est ce qu'on peut avoir un indice?
[F] C'est en 1981
[V] C'est un mathématicien ? ...
[F] Non
[V] Un scientifique ? c'est un mec qui bosse dans l'informatique donc il n'est pas tout à fait scientifique
[F] Oui voilà c'est ça!
[V] Est-ce qu'il est encore là aujourd'hui?
[F] Oui
[V] Il travaille encore dans l'informatique?
[F] Oui tout à fait
[C] Est-ce qu'il met une cagoule par contre quand il sort?
[F] Non, non, non
*Rire de Céline et Fabien
[V] Est ce qu'il est le patron d'un grand truc?
[F] Oui
[V] Il bosse pour une marque?
[V] Française du coup ?
[F] Non
[V] Ah ! C'est pas français
[V] Est ce que ça serait pas, genre un...
alors quel genre de groupe ? euh... Microsoft, Apple
l'un ou l'autre. Microsoft ?
[F] Ouais
[V] Microsoft ! Ben oui, en même temps
il n'y en a qu'un seul
c'est Bill Gates?
[F] Eh oui c'est Bill Gates
[V] Put**n
[F] Celui là il a parlé d'un produit.
Faut que vous trouviez le produit
[C] Allez vas y !
[F] Alain Sugar, homme d'affaire britannique en 2005
[V] Le sucre
*Rires*
[F] Bravo !
[V] C'est trop fort
[F] Alain Sugar, homme d'affaire politique en 2005 a dit
"A Noël prochain, tel produit, sera mort, fini, parti, kaputt"
[C] Il y a un peu plus de 10 ans...
[V] Il a dit "kaputt"?
[V] En 2005, on pouvait dire "kaputt". ça, c'est quand même vraiment génial.
[F] C'est... ben c'était la dernière année d'ailleurs.
[V] Ben, c'était le mot "Kaputt" qui était terminé. [F] Exactement! Bravo!
[V]Qu'est-ce que je voulais dire...Un télephone portable? [F] Non [V] Un tatoo?  [F] Non [C] je viens de le dire. Tu suis, tu suis, tu suis?
[V] Je ne vous écoute pas. C'est du jeu vidéo? [F] Non
[F] heu.. Lui, c'est un homme d'affaire  britannique.
[C] Pas d'ordinateur [V] mais électronique.
[V] Heu..une liseuse? Non, ça peut pas être ça... [F] Non
[V] C'est un clavier?  [F] Non. Mais est-ce que tu crois vraiment?! Qu'un mec en 2005, il a dit :"Le clavier les gars, il passera pas Noël! [Rires]
[V] J'en suis plus à réfléchir. Vraiment, il faut que je propose tout ce que j'ai sous la main. Une chaise? Un tabouret? Un bonnet de bain? [Rires]
[C] Des trucs! Des écouteurs! [F] Non, mais c'est pas mal. On commence à être dans l'univers.
[C] Oh l'enfer! [V] un Ipod? [F] OUIIIIIII! Un Ipod évidemment!
[V] Ah oui! Et il bossait où du coup ce mec? P*tain comme on a tourné pendant 8 heures! [C] Pour un Ipod quoi!
[F] Qui a dit : " Dans 100 ans, on considérera Chales baudelaire en littérature comme une simple curiosité"?
[V] C'est un rappeur? [Rires] [C] C'est Booba? [F] C'est pas Booba mais c'est pas mal.
[V] Mais c'est pas mal donc un rappeur. [C] C'est Lafouine! [F] Non mais pas du tout! Pas du tout! Non mais arrêtez!
[V] C'est un auteur? Un homme politique? [F] Il a dit ça en 1867.
[C] Est-ce que c'est un auteur? Lui-même? [F] Oui.[C] Verlaine? [F] Non.
[C] Victor Hugo? [V] Il était en 67. [C] Mais c'est ça le (plus dur)!
[V] Faut trouver le mec. Shakespeare? [F] Mais une tombe! [V] Molière? [C] Welbeck? Je ne sais pas.
[C] On imagine que c'est quelqu'un de quand même relativement connu. [F] Oui. [V] Evidemment [C] Sans quoi, tu nous n'aurais choisi ça pour nous.
[V] Rousseau? [F] Non [V] Voltaire? [F]Non [V] Diderot? [F] Non, il va l'avoir à force. Faut proposer des noms!
[F] En plus de ça, il l'a déclaré à l'occasion de la mort de Baudelaire donc ça veut dire qu'il l'aimait pas tellement.
[V] C'est quand même le mec "Je peux dire quelquechose? J'ai juste un truc à dire. C'est qu'une merde. Voilà, merci à tous et continuez à chialer.
[F] On va considérer que c'était une petite curiosité. Disons que le nom de famille de Charles Baudelaire est au début de l'alphabet.
La première lettre de son nom de famille. Et ben celui dont je parle, on est plus vers la fin.
[V] C'est entre Sadide et Voltaire [C] C'est zz...[Rires] C'est Zola! [F] OUIII![hurlements]
[V] Oh merde, y a un auteur avec un Z. Oh la vache! Sachez qu'on a commencé à tourner hier.  [Rires]
Douglas Cooper, historien de l'art britannique a parlé d'un peintre, vous allez devoir trouver qui en avril 90
[V] Picasso
[Fabien rajoute un point à Vérino sur sa feuille]
[C] ça s'appelle de l'anti-jeu. C'est complètement de l'anti-jeu! [Rires]
[F] C'est ça, c'est ça! Il a dit : "J'ai longuement regardé ses tableaux. Ceci sont des gribouillages incohérents,
executés par un vieillard frénétique dans l'antichambre de la mort.
[V] On a un peu tous dit ça quand on a vu Picasso pour la première fois.
[F] Voilà, c'est ça. [Rires] Mais n'empêche qu'effectivement il a les points, il a les points.[résigné] Je suis obligé de les donner.
[C] Alors très bien.[V] Faut du rythme dans la vie. On a passé une heure et demie sur Zola. [C] Autant pour moi
[C] CHAISE! BROUETTE!
Qui a dit : "Internet, on s'en fout. ça ne marchera jamais." [C] Mussolini! [F] Non
[V] C'est une personne éclairée en 2001? [lisant la couverture du livre] [F] Oui mais t'as pas de nom. [V] C'est ça le truc.
[F] C'était en 2001 et c'est quelqu'un que vous connaissez ou au moins vous connaissez sa fonction ou au moins vous connaissez la société où il travaille
[V] Télé [F] Non [V] Non, c'est la musique [F] Oui c'est dans la musique [V] C'est Pascal Nègre. [F] Oh joli!
[C]Là je dois (applaudir). [V] En fait, j'ai cherché quel était le genre de personne qui avait un applomb pour te dire les choses avec autant de (certitude).
[F] C'est ça. C'est le PDG d'Universal Music France.
[V] Pascal Nègre, il est comme ça. Il t'explique la vie. Il te dit que de toute façon, c'est sûr et certain et il va droit dans le mur.
[F] Qui a dit : "La France ne comptera pas de millions de chomeurs. Je m'y engage." [V] Mitterand [C] Mitterand
[C] Oh non ! [Rires]
[F] Donc là, il faut que je vous trouviez l'objet dont on parle
" La ... n'a aucune valeur commerciale immaginable. Qui donc accepterait de payer pour recevoir un message qui n'est envoyé à personne en particulier ?"
[C] les Katoo, les bip bip, les talkie walkie. J'en ai rien à foutre.
[V]Twitter.. Qui est prêt à payer pour recevoir...Donc c'est pas la télé... C'est pas la radio... [F] C'est la radio.
[C] Mais il a dit : "C'est pas la radio..." [Rires] [F] C'est vrai.
[F] Non mais si, tu as raison. Je ne compte pas de points des ces cas là.
[V] C'est pas la télé par hasard? En même temps, il y a une vraie logique derrière.
C'est-à-dire qu'effectivement on envoie un message qui est pour personne [C]Ouais ya un raisonnement
[V] mais en fait, c'est pour tout le monde.
[F] Qui a dit :" S'amuser avec le courant alternatif est une perte de temps."
[V] Est-ce que c'est un Tesla , un Volt? [F] Exactement, c'est dans ce genre de choses.
[F] Il parlait en fait de Georges Westinghouse qui ,lui, a inventé le courant alternatif.
[F] ça commence par un E. [C]Edisson [F] OUI! [Rires]
[V] Oh les boules! Cette injustice!
[F] Vous devez trouver le magazine qui a dit ça en 1936. "Jamais une fusée ne sera capable de quitter l'atmosphère de la Terre."
[C]Un journal? [F] Oui, c'est un journal. [C] Le Monde, Libération...[F] Pas français
[V] Le times [F] Pas exactement mais il y a le mot Times dedans [C] New Time [V] New York Times [C] Voilà.
[F] Réponse collégiale un point chacun
[F] De quel invention parlait-on? "Mon invention sera exploité pendant un certain temps comme une curiosité scientifique
mais à part cela, elle n'a aucune valeur commerciale quelle qu'elle soit".
[C] Micro-ondes [F] Non [V] Curiosité scientique...C'est la télé! [F] Non [V] Y a de l'image...C'est l'image? [F] Y a de l'image.
[V] C'est une fenêtre! Le mec qui a inventé la fenêtre [Rires] [F] Il peut y avoir du son ou ne pas en avoir .
[C] Une liseuse. La vidéo conférence pour euh.. Bip! C'est qui à la porte? [V] Le visiophone. [F] Non
Mes mimes sont particuliers [Rires] [V] Ce que j'aime, c'est de te voir te débattre toute seule dans un truc "la..la...pis...les..les..." [Rires]
[F] Si tu veux faire comme Vérino, il faut jeter après [C] Ah oui, il faut jeter
[V] J'étais choqué hier, on a joué avec ma femme et mon fils. Et mon fils, il nous a apporté à manger.
Et à un moment, Marion l'a fait tomber. Ca m'a vraiment énervé.
J'ai dû passer le balai imaginaire puis la balayette imaginaire. [C] Mais t'es jusquauboutiste. ça, c'est un peu l'une de tes qualités.
[V] Même là, j'ai encoré poser la balayette. [Rires]
Y a de l'image [C] Les montres tactiles [V] Le cinéma [F] Ouais. Le cinéma [C] 'Tain. J'en étais à une montre tactile.
[F] Est-ce que vous voulez qu'on remette tout en jeu sur la dernière en faisant une mort subite? [V] Moi, j'accepte la mort subite.
[F] Ouais parce que c'est surtout toi [V] Ouais parce que toi tu peux pas dire "Ah ben ouais". Moi j'accepte .[F] OK
Une réponse à la fois. (Vérino) tu seras le premier. C'est quand même toi qui a le plus de point.
Qui a dit : "l'année 1968, je la salue avec serénité.".
[V] On a le droit de poser des questions?
[F] Une réponse suivie d'une question.[V] Ah d'accord. D'abord ma réponse et ensuite, j'ai le droit de poser une question.
[F] Ce qui fait que ta question peut servir à l'autre. [V] Donc c'est quelqu'un qui voit le truc arriver. Brigitte Bardot.
[F] Faux. As-tu une question ou pas? [V] oui, est-ce que c'est un homme? [F] Oui [V] OK
[C] C'est donc un homme...[Rires] [V] Je sens que t'es deçue [C] Je suis super déçue! j'avais une piste mais...du genre féminin. Alors si c'est un homme...
[F] Tu sens tes aiselles là! Fais très attention. Je sais pas si c'est inspirant mais...[Rires]
[V] (inhaltion) ah 'tain le génie vient en moi [C] Johnny Hallyday [F] Non [C]Je sais bien
[F] As-tu une question? [C] Oui! [F]T'as vu, c'est terrible! tu as accès à une vraie information mais en même tps..[V] Tu voudrais pas trop (aider)
[C] C'est un homme...[V] C'est la même question! [Rires] [C] politico socialo...[V] humoristico...
cuisto...[F] sportif quoi! [Rires] Oui. [V] Un homme politique en 68
[V] je n'ai pas le nom mais du coup, en fait , qui était en 68 au pouvoir et s'est fait complètement défoncé?
Parce que le bouquin. Y a des trucs qui ne marcheront jamais. 'tain je suis en train de te donner des (Infos) [C] Non [V] Mais effectivement, c'était le boss à l'époque.
[C] Moi je dis le néant. [F] Le néant? Non [Rires] As-tu une question?[V] Par quel lettre ça démarre? Ah le prénom. Comme ca , je t'en donne pas trop (d'indices)
[F] Par un C. [C] Même avec ca, c'est pitoyable! C'est pathétique. Tu l'as toi? [V] Non mais tu peux poser une autre question.
[C] Mais parce que je suis vraiment sympa. Quel est la première lettre de son nom de famille?
[F] Un D. [ V] Un D. t'es vraiment sympa mais du coup...Claude D....[C] Mais qui est cette personne? Enfin!
[F] Si vous l'avez, mettez le en commentaire mais je pense que si vous l'avez , je vais avoir 8 milliards de commentaires
parce que là, je pense que la terre entière l'a sauf deux personnes qui sont assise sur ma droite. [C] Mais c'est pathétique.
[F] Et que quand ils sauront, ils diront "Ah 'tain mais..." [C] Autant que ca ? [F] Ouais
[C] Mais pourquoi? [V] D....D.... [F] Dékalékatan Dékalékatan Ohé Ohé
[V] En fait, le truc interessant, c'est qu'il nous dit qu'il y a deux syllabes et qu'il y a deux parties [F] Y a trois syllabes du coup
[V] et toi, t'as dit machin tiret nin nin nin et il t'a dit hop hop hop, c'est en deux partie donc y'a un D apostrophe quelquechose.
[C] Non [V] ben si.[C] Pas forcément [V] Si c'est en 2 parties et y a pas de trait d'union.
[C] Ben non , il peut y avoir de "de" quelquepart comme "de..." de la motte piquet.
[C] Charles de la Motte Piquet. [Rires]
[F] Oh P'tain, je l'adore! Abonnez-vous à cette meuf! Elle me fait rire beaucoup trop.
[V]Il a dit deux ou trois syllabes et c'est de quelquechose ou D apostrophe quelquechose. Donc ça se prononce d....
[F] Je cherche un endroit pour (me pendre) parce que je vous écoute depuis tout à l'heure.
Je vous dis le prénom ou pas? Ben, c'est Charles.
[C] Charles
Je ne connais pas cette personne. Je n'ai jamais pris un apéro avec cette personne.
Je suis confuse mais c'est vrai. Je suis désolée. [V] Est-ce qu'on peut avoir la deuxième lettre du nom de famille? [Rires]
[C] C'est ridicule!
[V] Je suis vraiment rassuré qu'on soit ridicule tous les deux. Quoique si y'avait un qui savait, on serait allé beaucoup plus vite.
[C] Est-ce que c'est Charles de? [F] Ouais [C] Charles de la Fon..[V] Attends, deux ou trois syllabes. Charles de...tata
[C] Charles De Gaulle! [F] Ben OUI! [Hurlements]
[C] J'en ai le souffle coupé! Charles De Gaulle!
[F] Charles DE GAU-LLE. C'est pour ca que je disais deux- trois (syllabes). [V] Non mais c'était deux syllabes
[C] Je vais te pourrir ton Facebook! [V] Ah ben tu peux y aller [C] Ton twitter, j'en sais rien!
Elles sont où les photos compromettantes?
[V] Ben elles sont dans ton téléphone aussi Céline. Tu le sais très bien.
[C] C'est vrai. [Rires] Ce moment génant.
Attends! On va mettre celle-là! [Rires] C'est ridicule!
[V] Moi quand je regarde la dernière vidéo de Céline H. Je suis ému.
[F] Et du coup, y a une photo compromettante de Vérino.Pour la voir, je vous mettrai le lien du twitter de Vérino dans la description. Vous irez voir sur son Twitter.
[V] Oh lalala..[C] C'est merveilleux. Mais j'adore cette photo.
[V] Pour être vraiment sincère, c'est que j'avais décidé de me raser pendant les vacances.
[F] Non mais n'en dit pas plus! Ils iront voir .[V] Et...[F] Et ils n'auront que ce début de phrase.
[C] Sa crédibilité va disparaître dans 3...2...1... Twitté!!
[F] Je suis ravi d'avoir eu Vérino et Céline pour cette vidéo. Je vous mets les liens de leurs chaînes dans les  descriptions. Allez checker ça.
Je vous mets aussi le Twitter de Vérino dans la description. En même temps, c'était pas facile Charles De...Charles De...
[F] Charles De Pompidou ! Charles De...Arrrgh, on ne sait pas! Charles De Chirac! [Rires] [V] On abuse
N'oubliez pas de liker la vidéo. Allez vraiment checker out leurs chaînes et vous abonner.
[V] Non, likez pas ça! Abonnez-vous à rien du tout. Barrez-vous! [C] Oh, il est mauvais joueur. Quel mauvais perdant!
Et rendez-vous vendredi pour la prochaine vidéo.
[V] Rendez-vous chez Decathlon. Du coup, je change de métier et je vends des chaussures chez Deca...Ah! On sait toujours pas. Ciao!
[V]  Ca a été un beau combat [C] J'ai apprécié ce moment. [V] Je pense qu'on peut dire qu'on est vraiment perdant.
[C] On est nul!!C'est la pire victoire du monde. [V] Ca  c'est les jeux de Fabien, tu sais qu'il a appris le botin par coeur cet abruti.
[C] Ouais mais je sais. [V] A un moment, faut arrêter de jouer avec Fabien Olicard.
[C] Je peux te dire que les dimanches quand je vais le voir, je m'éclate! [Rires]